you know Frankie Valli always sings his
song so high-pitched it's crazy I can't
even get Shh
Jersey Boys is directed by the one and
only Clint Eastwood it's the story of
Frankie Valli and the four seasons a
very famous band from back in the day
and how they started they had run-ins
with the mob they had to prove
themselves as singers they had
relationship problems all that kind of
stuff that you generally kind of see in
these musical biopics of sorts and in
this film sometimes it's handled well
and sometimes it isn't now I grew up
with the four seasons my dad had all of
their albums and I heard their songs all
the time as a youth and so there's
actually a lot of songs in this movie
that I really enjoyed hearing the actor
who was cast as Frankie Belle I did a
great job with the singing I mean he
basically sounds the same his it's very
very very similar and it makes sense
because this is actually one of the
actors involved with the Broadway play
Jersey Boys who plays Frankie Valli in
the Broadway play I read that Clint
Eastwood cast a lot of people from that
because he wanted to have actors who
were used to doing these songs over and
over and over again all night and that
definitely added to the musical element
of this film they had that down pat and
that was one of the best parts of this
movie in fact it pretty much was the
best part as a film though I didn't
really feel like this movie convinced me
that it needs to exist one of the best
musical biographies I have seen was
walked the line it told Johnny Cash's
story and it really got to the emotional
core of him as a person this film is
really missing that when it comes to
Frankie Valli's portrayal and the script
and the story it all just feels so
familiar like we've seen it so many
times before the rise of the musician
the fall of him the rise the fall drugs
alcohol violence
yeah love clint eastwood as a director
and an actor I love that guy but I don't
think he was the right director for this
project because he just didn't bring the
vibrancy in the energy that is needed
for a film that is so musically
explosive as this one was on paper
because I can tell that as a script this
could be a really great movie it feels
very good fella's ish in fact there's a
lot of good fellows and references in
this movie and I mean actual good
fellows references and some of it felt a
little bit too much like winking to the
audience because you could tell that the
script was trying to be more energetic
than Eastwood's directing was in Jersey
Boys there's a lot of breaking the
fourth wall
that's characters talking directly to
you acknowledging the audience is
actually watching them but the movie is
not directed with that kind of
exuberance that is needed to make that
really fun it's all very laid-back and
kind of relaxed and that is Eastwood a
lot of his films do feel that way but
for this movie it needed to have a lot
more punch to it Christopher Walken is
in this film and not in enough because
all the scenes he's in he's fantastic as
usual he's awesome to watch and not just
because he's Christopher Walken he just
brought like this maturity to the movie
you know you just felt like this
seasoned maturity all of a sudden just
showed up whenever he came into a scene
and he did a great job with his role as
a movie about Frankie Valli you don't
really feel that much for him you just
don't really get to know him that well
the majority of the movie is other
characters talking to the screen you
really don't get to learn that much
about him you just kind of see things
happen to him there's one great scene in
this movie it's a very long scene
involving this argument between people
over money it was handled very well and
it was the best scene in the film the
singing in the film is good there's a
lot of good songs but for the most part
Jersey Boys is just kind of boring which
is really unfortunate because this movie
could have been so energetic and fun I'm
gonna give Jersey Boys a see it's a
movie that could have been a lot better
than it was and unfortunately just
wasn't directed with the energy that it
needed guys thank you so much for
watching if you have seen this film let
me know what you thought of it what's
your favorite Clint Eastwood directed
movie because he's made some pretty
awesome ones thanks guys and if you like
this you can click right here and get
stuck Munoz
you